let's talk about Starbucks they're
actually doing something that's pretty
cool
they've announced that they're going to
be paying for
tuition for two years online classes at
Arizona State University for
some other employees we've got more info
about seventy percent of Starbucks
a hundred thirty-five thousand US
employees have not completed
undergraduate degrees
employees can now choose any more than
40 undergraduate degrees in art limited
to only business classes so you can do
whatever you want which is cool because
a lot of people working at Starbucks
are doing it so they can become artists
or whatever they whatever they want to
be
employees are required to stay with the
company after receiving their degrees
and tuition is approximately
30,000 for two years to bill I mean
Israel they're the real investment that
they're making
with their place understanding that
these people are not always gonna be
with them and they're gonna go to fill
their own dreams
a pretty great right its of them
up to get a job at Starbucks yeah but
it's fantastic because
a lot of times you didn't stop and
there's wanna hold you there they don't
want to grow they want to stay in your
position so they can make money
of love you this is like the complete
rivers they're giving you money and
giving you wings we can fly into
something else yeah
expect so isn't that the real beauty in
this whole operation it's totally
counterintuitive do business model to
get you to a place for you don't have to
work at that company anymore
and I'm suspicious only question I can
smell
I don't know what I don't even know what
a special but I'm not suspicious because
this is it seems too good to be true
they don't care what you major and
they'll pay for it they don't care
if you start a if you work at Starbucks
continue all my classes
and quit they don't really care as long
as you're working what twenty hours a
week
its to a good I'm afraid they're gonna
get hatch by how much does this kind of
that make you want to go
to Starbucks so when you hear that they
give all their employees health
insurance you know before Obamacare
whatever
did that affect even if their coffee
isn't the greatest like to think very
good but if you re
I don't even care if they burn their
beans I so excited that they're doing
there I think I've
really and truly people threat the
American history you join the military
to get a benefit like that
yeah and this is just you know make a
couple double lot they've got like 200
dealing with people in the morning
before they had a coffee can be quite
like a war
you know proprietary your eyes sure I
just think this is so
phenomenon I just hope that we're all
not being duped because it's so good and
it's
it's just so good at them yeah how much
in this comes the thing from like
just a business perspective not just
people talking about it like we're
talking about and they get that good
that goodwill verses like sorta but real
genuine caring
for their employees may not matter which
actually yeah I think
we all to corporations that a person
right
well complain about a five dollar lot
today but if you're not telling me
all a dollar a beer five dollars goes
the help young men in here
achieve her goal being the neurosciences
cardiac yeah
bad about my coffee cucumber
neuroscientist at
online at Arizona State University that
might not make it what she gathered her
I don't make this about that
me to grab your life